.
>> IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE CANADA
NICE RIGHT THERE.
PAULA NEWTON, THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
>>> DEVELOPING, THE UNITED
RUSSIA PARTY THAT SUPPORTS
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS ON TRACK TO
KEEP ITS MAJORITY ON PARLIAMENT
AFTER THIS WEEK'S ELECTION.
CRITICS ARE ACCUSING OFFICIALS
OF BLATANT FRAUD WHERE
OPPOSITION WAS STIFLED.
MATTHEW CHANCE IS LIVE IN MOSCOW
WITH MORE.
MATTHEW.
>> Reporter: BRIANNA, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
A BIG WIN FOR THE PARTY THAT
SUPPORTS VLADIMIR PUTIN.
BUT THAT WIN HAS COME AMID
WIDESPREAD ALLEGATIONS OF
ELECTION RIGGING AND THE FACT
THAT THE REAL OPPOSITION IN THIS
COUNTRY HAVE NOT BEEN PERMITTED
TO STAND AT ALL.
RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN CASTING THEIR
VOTES, BUT THE CRITICS THIS IS
DEMOCRACY AT ITS WORST.
ACCUSING THE KREMLIN OF BLATANT
ELECTION FRAUD, SOME ACTUALLY
CAUGHT ON OFFICIAL CAMERAS.
WATCH THE WOMAN IN BLACK ON THE
RIGHT.
AWKWARDLY TRYING TO SHIELD THE
BALLOT BOX AS A HAND APPEARS
FROM BEHIND THE RUSSIAN FLAG.
YOU CAN SEE IT REPEATEDLY
STUFFING PAPERS INSIDE.
ELECTION OFFICIALS SAY THEY HAVE
A NULLED THESE FOLKS.
BUT CRITICS SAY THOUSANDS OF
VIOLATIONS, INCLUDING BALLOT BOX
STUFFING AND FORCED VOTING, ARE
BEING IGNORED.
IN TOTAL, 12 CASES OF BALLOT
STUFFING IN THE WHOLE COUNTRY IN
JUST EIGHT DISTRICTS, THE CHIEF
ELECTION COMMISSIONER BRAGS ON
STATE MEDIA.
THIS IS NOT HYPE LIKE SOME
MISINFORMATION SOURCES, SHE
ADDS.
FROM SELF-IMPOSED COVID-19
QUARANTINE NEAR MOSCOW, THE
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT IS
SCHOENEWEISING A CONTROVERSIAL
ONLINE VOTING SYSTEM WHICH LOWS
EVEN MORE OPPORTUNITY TO
MANIPULATE RESULTS.
THE SYSTEM NEEDS A MOBILE PHONE
FOR VERIFICATION.
AND THERE ARE QUESTIONS HOW
PUTIN, WHO INSISTS HE NEVER USES
ONE, WAS ABLE TO CAST HIS VOTE.
THE KREMLIN SAID HE USED
ASSISTANCE DENYING THIS WHOLE
SCENE WAS STAGED.
BUT CRITICS ACCUSE THE KREMLIN
OF CAREFULLY ENSURING A WIN
DESPITE FLAGGING OPINION
POLLSINGS NOT JUST FOR THE
INFAMOUS POISONING OF ALEXEI
NAVALNY NEXT YEAR, WHICH
OFFICIALS DENY, BUT THE MOVES
SINCE THEN, BRANDING HIS
SUPPORTERS EXTREMISTS, BANNING
THEM AND OTHER OPPOSITION
FIGURES FROM STANDING FOR
OFFICE.
ONE RIGHTS GROUP ESTIMATES
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
ACTIVISTS HAVE BEEN AFFECTED.
THE RULING UNITED RUSSIA PARTY,
THE TEAM HAVE SMART VOTING EWING
APPS AND VIDEOS TO SHOW RUSSIANS
WHICH CANDIDATES, MOSTLY OLD
KPHOPL TPHEUFTS, STAND THE BEST
CHANCE OF UNSEATING INCUMBENTS.
BUT EVEN KREMLIN CRITICS WHO
HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO STAND SAY
THEY FACE EXTRAORDINARY
PRESSURE.
LIKE THIS CANDIDATE IN ST.
PETERSBURG WHO FOUND RIVALS HAVE
H ADOPTED HIS NAME AND
APPEARANCE TO CONFUSE VOTERS.
RUSSIA'S OWN ELECTION OFFICIALS
HAVE CALLED THIS A DISGRACE.
WE MET ONE VETERAN ANTI KREMLIN
ACTIVIST BARRED FROM STANDING AT
A MOSCOW POLLING STATION.
HE ADMITS THIS MAY BE LOST BUT
KREMLIN EFFORTS TO CLING TO
POWER INDEFINITELY, HE SAYS,
WILL BACKFIRE.
>> WE HAVE A SITUATION IN RUSSIA
WHERE THERE IS AN ENTIRE
GENERATION OF PEOPLE THAT HAS NO
OTHER POLITICAL POWER OTHER THAN
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
HE HAS BEEN IN POWER 20 YEARS.
SOONER OR LATER, PEOPLE WILL
CHANGE THE GOVERNMENT.
>> ANOTHER RUSSIAN REVOLUTION.
.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, YEAH.
IT GIVES ME NO PLEASURE TO SAY
THIS.
>> Reporter: BUT FOR NOW
REVOLUTION SEEMS A LONG WAY OFF.
EVEN WINNING A SINGLE SIT IN
THIS TIGHTLY CONTROLLED RUSSIAN
ELECTION WILL BE SOMETHING OF AN
OPPOSITION COUP.
IN FACT, THE RUSSIAN COMMUNIST
PARTY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE LAST
RUSSIAN REVOLUTION HAS DONE
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER IN THIS
ELECTION.
IT'S UP TO 20% OF THE VOTE.
IN THE PAST FEW YEARS, THEY HAVE
BEEN COMPLIANT WITH THE